they won't be putting the balloons out
for Secretary of State Anthony blinken
when he touches down in Beijing
relations between the U.S and China are
at their lowest point in years this trip
was due to take place in February
canceled after a Chinese spyballoon Flew
Over the U.S and was eventually shot
down intense competition requires
sustained diplomacy to ensure that
competition does not Veer into
confrontation or conflict
and again that is what the world expects
of both the United States and China this
trip is aimed at stabilizing relations
between the world's two biggest
economies and strategic rivals in recent
weeks the US has claimed a Chinese jet
performed aggressive Maneuvers near a
spy plane in international airspace and
that coming after a Chinese warship
allegedly narrowly avoided a collision
with the U.S destroyer in the Taiwan
Strait
the trip is looking to set up systems to
avoid similar incidents and to keep any
reaction to just a war of words
Anthony blinken goes with a shopping
list he wants to hear about China's
peace plan for Ukraine and to urge them
not to give military support to Russia
he will also top trade Taiwan human
rights and what China regards as U.S
efforts to hold back its semiconductor
industry you know there are limits to
U.S influence and and leverage and
certainly when it comes to its its
Rivals and competitors like like China
that uh indeed you know even if the US
is hoping for a certain outcome Beijing
is going to be impelled by its own
interests which of course are oftentimes
at odds with those of the United States
Joe Biden met president XI at the G20 in
Indonesia last year their first
face-to-face since Biden won the White
House since then China has said the U.S
must stop interfering in China's
Internal Affairs and stop harming its
sovereignty security and development
interests in the name of competition the
Americans are playing down the idea that
the blinken visit will lead to a summit
between the two presidents either here
at the white house or in Beijing but it
will lead to other top level meetings
and that suggests that the tension
between the two superpowers is easing
but not yet going away Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera at the White House